we don't have authorization to take him
shouts the military paramedic a wounded
Ukrainian soldier with a tourniquet on
each leg to slow the bleeding is lifted
from the car okay we've got to go
further down the road let's move now
from an ambulance point on a virtually
deserted road we drive towards solidar
we pass a few Ukrainian military
vehicles heading the other way
there's no obvious sign of a Ukrainian
withdrawal from the salt mining town
that seen some of the most intense
fighting in recent days
Army Medics waited intervals along the
way to take the injured to hospitals
back from the front line
as the battle continues we have to stay
in place if we could wait closer we
would but we are ready to move for
injured soldiers or civilians
the soldiers say the road over the brow
of the hill is being shelled
Russia says it's taken full control of
solidar but the smoke rising from Impact
sites the explosions from almost
constant artillery and heavy machine gun
fire suggests otherwise
Ukrainian troops
in these apcs these armored personnel
carriers heading towards solidar
it's only a couple of kilometers down
this road
troop carriers at tree lines seem
prepared for a potential withdrawal of
soldiers
there's Western supplied Weaponry here
but a lot of its Soviet made this
anti-aircraft gun is almost 60 years old
it will be hard for us to push them back
we'll suffer big losses they move in
such great numbers in solidar that
sometimes are guns overheat as we try to
shoot as many as we can
soldiers dig fresh trenches on a slope
in case Russian forces push up from the
valley
others watch the battle unfold
Ukrainian forces still have a foothold
in the western outskirts of the town
they say
fight for solidar isn't over yet Charles
Strafford Al Jazeera near solidar
eastern Ukraine